this is my problem with the right they
think they have the right to decide who
people want to look up to and they want
to police who men look up to maybe
there's a reason outside of the
campsites why men look up to tape I'm
sorry I have done hundreds of interviews
Street interviews hate is the topic all
the time on my show we always cover him
I have not talked to a single man that
said I started a campsite because of
Tate I have talked to many men that said
they started working out they started
cutting toxic women out of their life
I've heard many men say they wanted to
make more money all the good things but
the right if a guy is too
unapologetically masculine they will
look for anything to crucify that man
for even though he is not guilty at this
point